now russian forces have launched an
all-out assault in the south working to
seize parts of the donbass region but
ukrainian troops have pushed russia out
of harkiev where residents have been
bombarded for weeks with the city's
metro reopening today there's finally
some optimism about a return to normalcy
our jeff semple is in harkeef tonight
and joins us now with more jeff
chris when we visited harkev back in
march ukraine's second largest city
appeared on the brink of falling to the
russians but today we saw a much
different reality during the first weeks
of war families sheltered underground
huddled together in subway stations to
avoid the bombing above but two months
later their lives are slowly getting
back on track
subway service in harkev resumed tuesday
for the first time since russia's
invasion and commuters were on board
it's excellent it feels like things are
returning to the way they were before
this passenger says
the mayor of harkev whom we met two
months ago in a secret bomb shelter
appeared this time in public
and told reporters we need to restart
the economy people must be able to get
to work
this russian-speaking city sits on
russia's doorstep just 40 kilometers
away but ukraine has pushed russian
forces back almost to the border and it
seems some left in a hurry this was a
russian tank that is until it was
captured by the ukrainian forces in a
battle with the russians in harkev last
month and the ukrainians brought it here
to this secret location so that
ukrainian soldiers can train and learn
how to use it so this is a look inside
they say it's similar in many ways but
it's a newer model and it's much faster
so they have to learn how to handle it
they say that this thing can go up to
100 kilometers an hour in fact they've
nicknamed it the flying tank
in three months the ukrainians have
captured more than 240 russian tanks
they say they even use this one to
attack a russian battalion and kill its
commanders
enemy has gone from attacking to
defending this ukrainian sergeant says
our spies say the russians are
demoralized but while the city hopes the
worst is over the scars of war are
brutal
this family survived the bombing of
their apartment building and came to
inspect their son's kindergarten across
the street
they found his school playground full of
fragments from russian rockets
russia says it's attacking military
targets but this is a quiet neighborhood
with schools and houses she says the
family called the ordnance disposal unit
to remove this grad rocket from beneath
the play structure this
the rockets are everywhere he says in
the span of just a couple of hours his
unit was called to remove ordinance from
this apartment kitchen a nearby parking
lot and yet another kindergarten
playground none of us i'm angry says the
father of a one-year-old
i want to kill the people who did this
with my bare hands officials say about a
third of all apartment buildings in
harkiev have been damaged or destroyed
and they've also updated the death toll
more than 700 people killed including at
least 36 children
chris
jeff semple in harkeev ukraine thank you
jeff